- [Kelly Clarkson] What has
been the best thing about
coaching so far?
- [Ariana Grande] Other than
just getting to know you all
and spend that time and laugh so hard,
I just love seeing the talent
that's on the show and getting
to know these artists and work with them.
It's just like a really special
experience to be able to
share some of what we've learned
and been able to do in our
lives with these artists that
are just wanting to do the
same thing.
It's a really special opportunity
to be able to share that
with people to be in that
position is really interesting.
It's just so cool to be there. And yeah,
they're all so nice and cool. I love them.
I'm obsessed with my team. I
talked to them all the time.
- You got your first team too.
It's like, you get so upset.
You love them all. But like, it's like.
- I've broken every rule
in my contract.
- [Kelly] (laughing)
Talk to them all, all the
time. I'm like, DM-ing them.
They're like, you're
not supposed to do that.
And I'm like, sorry.
- No, no.
You're sending stuff to the
hotel for that. You're very,
this is the coolest
thing about you though.
I really hope people get to see from you.
Like just working with you
on the show like backstage,
like, I have to have my eye makeup redone,
like she's hysterical. She's so funny.
Very quick witted. I
didn't know this about you.
I knew you were talented, I
knew you'd be a great coach.
I know all those things,
but I didn't know how funny
you were because we'd never
really hung much.
- I just, lifeless. I know.
- [Kelly] This is lifeless.
- Seems totally, no, I get it.
- When we're watching you, we
only see, like, performing.
- For sure, and like, Seven
Rings, which is like, what?
Who is that? You know?
- Well, that's a great song.
So, yeah.
- [Ariana] Thank you. But like
what does that even?
That's like, one of my favorites.
- You know what I mean,
that's not a person.
- It's a (laughing) it's not a
- [Ariana] Punchline.
- She's a robot.
- You know what I mean?
That's a punchline.
- No, no, but you're hilarious.
And I thought it was so interesting
because usually it takes
coaches that come on,
like just being there for eight seasons,
it takes them a minute to like,
get used to like, being free
with like their words and like
their personality. And
you kind of like, right.
It was like, I think the second
or third day of the blinds,
you were like, nevermind, I'm here.
And it was like, awesome.
Do you, did you find it nerve wracking?
- It was a little nerve wracking,
but you all made me feel so
comfortable and are the nicest
people that I've met in this whole thing.
Like just the most fun ever.
And you made me feel so comfortable.
So it's because of you guys,
you guys were pushing and
also Blake was pushing all the
buttons. Sorry.
I'll shut up.
- Yes, he, no, he wasn't,
but that's but you know
what he does though?
Because he feels able to.
That's when I feel like
it's the best chemistry. Yeah.
It's helpful. It sets you up for jokes.
- It does. He gives you
a good, a good setup
every time.
- He just opens his mouth. Yeah.
- That's it.
He just walks in.
- Well, they act tough.
He just walks in and it's,
there's a joke coming,
but Blake and John are,
they are terrified of you; look at this.
- [Ariana] Oh.
- Yes.
- [John Legend] Ariana has a huge fan base
and they are fervent.
And if they show up to
vote, we're all in trouble.
- 100%. Are you scared at all?
- [Blake Shelton] No.
I'm not afraid of her fan
base. Where are they at?
Look, where's the cameras.
Bring it on. I'm not afraid of Ariana.
- He is so afraid about Ariana's fan base.
Thoughts? You, we said this
when you came in, I mean,
it was apparent, literally
the entire audience
was screaming.
We're like, we have no
chance like. It was like,
It was amazing.
- [Ariana] I don't know that
that's true.
- [Kelly] Well, I'm just
saying, like, you have a...
- I really do not think that's
true. I mean,
- But you're, like a,
You're a huge star. I don't know.
News flash. No.
- What are you talking about?
Kelly Clarkson?
- No, what?
No, I'm just saying, like,
it's one of those things
(audience claps)
like you watch out, and...
- Is she okay?
- Sorry.
- No! It's so different.
Anyway, we're all, it's
got to feel a little good,
like, little bit of
competitiveness in you.
It's gotta be like, they're
all a little terrified.
- I really don't think
that I have the chance
you think I have.
- You can think all you want,
but it's true.
- First of all,
the beautiful thing about
it is that even just
being on the show,
this is such a beautiful chance
for them to be seen by the
world in a new way.
- Yeah.
- This is just us getting to
meet them and give them this
first chance.
And it's really special
- Big opportunity.
because I think you're going to fall
in love with all of them. I really do.
- They're so good.
- Yeah. - They're so good.